PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Today, we're talking
about code samples, security,
and a different kind
of chatbot.
I am Priyanka, and welcome to
"This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
For the first time ever,
cloud.google.com's code samples
can be searched from
a single location.
So far, the search page
includes 8,600 code samples
across seven
programming languages
with language, product, and
keyword filters available.
Check out the blog post
to learn more or head over
to
cloud.google.com/docs/samples.
Join us for our first Google
Cloud Security Talks of 2021--
a live online event
on March 3, where
we will help you navigate
the latest in cloud security.
Reserve your virtual seat now
to hear experts discuss topics
like risk management,
information governance
in Google Workspace, machine
learning to better protect
networks, the future of
confidential computing,
and more.
Getting the job
you want requires
you to stand out to
potential employers,
especially in the
current job market.
Recently, one of our
customer engineers
did just that by building
a conversational chatbot
on Google Cloud that
answers questions
about professional experience.
Plus some surprises.
Check out a new way to stand
out and learn more on the blog.
If you want to stop those
clever phishing attacks,
use security keys.
A security key is
a physical device
that works alongside your
user name and password
to verify your identity
to a site or an app.
They produce stronger
login protection
than an authenticator
app or SMS code.
And the same device can
be used for many services.
So you don't need
to carry around
a necklace of dongles or fobs.
In this issue of GCP Comics,
we are covering exactly that.
Check it out for more.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.